[Music]
matt is with us in phoenix
hey matt how are you great how are you
doing today
better than i deserve what's up so
i um have been following the baby steps
for a few years now me and my wife
probably about five and i'm actually a
big advocate i love what you preach and
i've probably got a half dozen over the
years about a half dozen clients that
i've kind of deferred you guys away so i
never really thought i'd find myself
in this situation uh basically my wife
and i thought we were
gonna pay off our house um and that's
kind of where we're at we don't have any
debt all our cars are
free and clear and we don't carry credit
card debt and
uh we had this opportunity come up this
year a very niche real estate
opportunity where basically we got to
use buy and hold rental properties
and we were using
our our primary house we did i'm sure
you're familiar with the product
all in one mortgage it's basically a
line of credit that's
taxed as the first mortgage with a
checking component built into it
and so anyways we we bought four
investment properties this year
uh on a whim because they cash flowed
really well
we did 15 down loans no mi
uh or pmi and um and
uh basically the mortgage payments are
between 800 to a thousand dollars a
piece
and they cash flow about four thousand
dollars a month well
their gross is four thousand so they
cash flow about three grand and we
bought four of these and
obviously it's been great for us um it's
really kind of accelerated our debt
payoff
instead of looking to have our primary
house paid off
in 2022 we're probably going to get paid
off sometime
next year in 2021 um the thing that
we're running into
is as we did this because we've always
kind of followed the
you know not leveraging uh uh approach
um well i think my wife and i have both
kind of
gotten nervous that we've pulled out um
yeah about six hundred thousand dollars
in mortgage debt between the four houses
even though they're cash flowing really
well um and the opportunity basically
none of these houses have any vacancy um
and we're getting pressured to get even
more
um because we literally have a waiting
list of tenants that want to move in
because of the kind of niche opportunity
it is
so my question to you is if we can still
get our primary house paid off
uh next year and um continue to grow
into these other
you know buy and hold properties do you
think this is a a bad
like do you think we're is this a
formula for misfortune that we keep
you know snagging some of these with the
cash flow being as good as they are
i'm a little confident do you think
we're still going to stop stop staying
i'm a little confused okay i thought you
started this call with how you had
listened to us and followed us for years
yeah yeah okay then you know then you
know the answer to the question
if you've listened to me and followed me
for years you've never heard me tell
people to do what you're doing
yeah it's true okay that's true and i
certainly wouldn't tell you to do more
of what you're doing
right yeah you followed the plan you
followed the plan until you stopped
following the plan
exactly exactly and so
so that that's just kind of like it's
it's basically come into another source
of income for us and
hey listen listen listen go ahead i have
a source of income too
several hundred million dollars have
paid for real estate
that never had a mortgage on it once and
i did not use leverage to build it i
used cash to build it
matt you're going to get in trouble
because you have not
factored risk into this scenario
and leverage is a two-edged sword it
cuts
both ways
here are the phrases you have just
continued to say things all through this
conversation that indicates you have
no measure of risk whatsoever okay dave
you own more real estate than anybody
else i know
i want you to hear these phrases niche
real estate
niche yeah yeah okay hold on bought four
properties on a whim
and was being pressured to buy more
what what what what are we what are we
doing here
it sounds like late night real estate
get rich quick scheme
103. it's a bad plan
and it's got headache and heartache
written all over it down the road here
in just a few years my friend
and the other thing is after talking to
you for four minutes or listening to you
talk for four minutes
nothing more you say is gonna change it
nope